si vous êtes de nature jaloux jalouse
sachez qu'il y a une appli qui peut vous
dire si votre chéri est inscrit sur une
appli de rencontre si vous voulez le
savoir il faudra dépourser la somme de
18 euros quand même mon copain est-il
sur tinder un site permet de le
découvrir et ouais ça c'est une appli et
là il faut bien Daniel arrête Daniel
arrête de faire cette tête là tu es pas
du tout concernée
il doit s'appeler il doit s'appeler
petit vieux coquin
elle sera pas déçue non non c'est vous
vous étiez sur tinder oui j'ai déjà été
sorti alors bien sûr
des célébrités
qui s'appelle rya et normalement c'est
une application uniquement il faut
demander à être sur l'appli il laisse
passer deux jours regarde tes Facebook
ce que tu as fait et six fois que tu es
connu Ken star il t'accepte du coup
c'est une appli que pour Star qui
veulent se rencontrer entre stars la
dernière fois
Daniel c'est pas mal pour toi
ils ont accepté Mathieu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le magazine qui les a tous les deux ans
qui s'appelle merde
au magazine
comment il s'appelle un truc là tu as
jamais été à 90 j'étais à 89 j'arrive
[Rires]
du monde qui est connu et qui a une
carrière 65 ans
[Applaudissements]
spectateurs il y a un magazine très
sérieux qui faisait chaque année le taux
de notoriété des animateurs
et c'est vrai que Mathieu Delormeau ils
avaient calculé je crois c'est un
autorité je pense que tu étais pas 50 %
je te jure 70
il y a 3 ans bah depuis 450 tu as perdu
la notoriété pourquoi parce que tu es
devenu encore plus con
et là tu dois être là tu dois être à 70
ah j'avoue 80 allez 75 ans
il y avait Cyril il y avait il y avait
euh
c'est vrai les deux plus les deux plus
connus en notoriété je veux dire que
c'est vrai c'était ça qui était fou mais
moi c'était j'avais je crois Stéphane
Bern Michel Drucker et moi ouais 97 %
oui c'est ça absolument
toujours
bien placé toujours bien placé
toujours près de moi
[Applaudissements]